thank you very much for quite very show
so we're in a school what's your plan
for education if you become Prime
Minister well I think education is the
single most important thing that we
conservatives believe in in the sense
that it is the tool every kid should
have to make the most of their talents
and their opportunities and a great
education is the job of the state to
provide - to absolutely everybody and
the what's been happening in the UK over
the last few years is that too many
schools been falling behind in the per
capita provision so what I want to do
day one is level up and make sure that
everybody primary schools and secondary
schools get the funding they need we're
also announcing today something for
special educational needs schools as
well so what is that that you're
announcing well what we want to do is to
give parents the ability where they
think there's need to go for a special
educational needs at schools for free
schools and we will back that up and
we'll support them because I think very
often local authorities need that extra
help to make sure they have enough
provision nearby so what's that mean
sorry more money for it will but it's
part of our overall package of about 4.6
billion so just let me get this straight
so you want to put more money into
schools I do you want to put more money
into transport on the North you want to
roll out full fibre broadband to every
house in the country you want to put
20,000 more police on the streets and
you also want to cut taxes I mean come
on that's having a cane using it well
actually of course there is the great
Tunisian scholar and sage even cardoon
pointed out as early as the 14th century
there are plenty of taxes that you can
cut which will actually increase your
revenues and there are ways of making
sure that you stimulate growth you
stimulate enterprise and you get more in
but what is certainly true is at the
moment Sophie
there is cash available and we're going
to make sure where's that cash available
then it's well as the head remover of
about 20 to 25 billion at the moment and
you know Barry's doesn't every month I
mean there's Headroom because when
people pay taxes
all that kind of thing isn't there
varies but there's definitely there's
definitely Headroom and if you look at
the February alone and the Chancellor's
revenues exceeded his expenditures
because that's when people tend to pay
tax if you look at different months then
actually new in deficit
well there is believe me there is cash
now available are you prepared to see
borrowing go up well I think at the
moment there is the Headroom available
and we intend to use it and I also think
that you can do some great things to
stimulate economic growth it's very
simple question are you prepared to see
borrowing go up if it's borrowing to
finance great infrastructure projects
and there's a there's the opportunity to
to borrow it low rates to do long things
for the long-term benefit of the country
then we should do them but when there
are some projects they forget in this
country we're spending about two hundred
and fifty billion pounds on public
procurement per year at one kind or
another don't tell me there aren't
significant savings to be found in the
way that we spend that money I tell you
how we do so you see that's a straight
answer to my question but I'm prepared
to borrow to finance certain great
objectives but overall we will keep its
first fiscal responsibility and keep
going with the general trajectory
ensuring that this country pays its way
and lives within its means but you can
do that with some sensible tax cuts that
will stimulate growth stimulate
enterprise get more revenue in what
talking also also use the the Headroom
we've currently got to spend on things I
think are really important so what I
think that we should be looking at
lifting people on low incomes out of
lifting the thresholds for national
insurance and I would remind you that
that's where my priority is and when I
was mayor of London we led the way for
instance with the London living wage and
I think lifting ni contribution
thresholds will be another good thing to
do you're talking about people on no
income that's one way that could really
help them is to look at the minimum wage
labor want to raise that to ten pounds
now would you match that well I
certainly believe in lifting the living
wage and I'm not going to set a figure
now as you know there is a process by
which that figure is determined I
released support the impartiality and
the fact-based way that is done and
wouldn't want to interpose my own
judgement now on this on this show but
look at what I did when I was met we
massively expanded the living wage we
put cash into the pockets of the poorest
families across ton I'm incredibly proud
of that this country needs higher pay
not higher taxes that's what I want to
achieve what is the living wage now then
well it's it's at or around eight past
twenty one well it's right forgive me
that's quite significantly lower there
sorry I'm talking about the London
English do you think that's not a little
a problem what you want to know I
believe me we but I believe in expanding
the living wage where it's possible okay
now I'm keen to talk about brexit number
one on the intro for whoever is going to
end up in Downing Street now you've said
that you want to leave all of 31st of
October do-or-die you've also said that
you want to do it we're going to die
that's we should leave I think that I
think that what we will face is a
political extinction and we will
literally I think there will be a we
will have a drift away from not just the
Conservative Party but from both the
means I think it will I think it will
suffer very considerably from an
electorate that feels that they can't
trust politicians to deliver on their
promises how far would you be willing to
go then to ensure that we do I mean
would you be prepared to ignore and
peace if they and try and block UK
leaving well this is your this is the
sort of parading about suspending
Parliament to push something through yes
and I think what's much more important
is that MPs understand the gravity of
the situation
and behave with responsibilities and
recognize that the only way to restore
trust and confidence in politics is to
get this thing done so you won't rule it
out I don't like the idea of pierogi I'm
not remotely attracted to it but you
know MPs have got to understand it's
their responsibility to get this thing
done and that was by far by far the best
solution I don't I don't want to provoke
Parliament nor do I expect to I don't
think that's going to be necessary and I
think it's far more important that MPs
focus on on where we are because
politics has changed since March the
29th and people can see that unless we
get brexit done there is going to be a
continuing hemorrhage of trust and of
confidence in my party and and labour
who I'm in labor with a spectacular
incompetence managed to go backwards in
the council elections as well
and we're talking about the reality of
how we're going to get brexit done if
you are so certain to leave at the end
of October then there is a chance that
is considerably less than a million to
one that we will leave with no deal I
just want to have a look at three quotes
that you leaders have said it just in
the last month alone jean-claude Juncker
there will be no renegotiations as far
as the content of the withdrawal
agreement is concerned leave errotica
there is no withdrawal agreement without
a backstop Angela Merkel the exit
agreement has been finalized this is
before it was reported that you referred
to French people as turds so I can't
imagine the situation has improved great
in the last 24 hours or so so if you are
saying that you're not willing to extend
and they're not willing to negotiate
then we're going to be leaving with no
deal if your Prime Minister well
actually I think that our European
friends and partners can see very
clearly what the answer is what they're
saying I don't think that they are going
to want a disorderly brexit of any kind
and it's not in their interest there's
no reason why they should want the
sudden imposition of tariffs and quotas
so just you're just ignoring what
they're saying
they would say that at this particular
stage in the in the negotiations you'd
expect them to say that kind of thing
we're going to work very hard to show
our earnestness our sincerity what we
want to do is to take the the elements
of the current withdrawal of reamed and
really doesn't work at all it's a
defunct agreement but there are some
good bits so I'd like to get about
citizens we should pass that through the
money the 39 billion
I would suspend that in creative
ambiguity wait till we get a deal and
then solve the problems of the of the
Northern Irish border and in those
quotes that is not going to happen well
you know let's see let's be upfront
about what No Deal could mean it would
mean terrorists wouldn't it well I mean
what were the terrorists beyond cars of
the leopard made oh we don't that is not
the objective I want that is not the
objective I seek and it would be I think
the very very very very strange if the
EU were to go for a solution in which
their vehicles coming to the UK in huge
numbers by the way faced attacks now
there are some people I like Mervyn King
the former governor of the Bank of
England do you think so you know that
would be that would be very good that we
Drake in 35 billion euros in in tariffs
for theirs after all the EU has a
colossal surplus with us in in in good I
don't want that at all I think that
would be that's not the way to go it
doesn't make any sense
well the way forward safety is to have a
standstill in the current range which
you need that you to agree with you do
but for the reasons I've just given I
think they have a powerful incentive to
get it done and I go further and I go
further and say that actually when when
you consider they there have now since
March the 29th they have a large
contingent of Euroskeptic British any
peas in Strasbourg a continual thorn in
their side they are going to want to get
this thing over the line a year ago when
you were asked about businesses concerns
about anodal brexit you reportedly say
it's not that was that was not the
context of the did you say that my words
have been totally taken out of context
I'll tell you I was being told that
there was absolutely no way that the UK
could leave the single market and the
customs union and that we would have to
stay run by the EU and I don't think
that is the case and I think actually if
you look at my record as somebody who
has campaigned for business who was
stuck up for business through thick and
thin I don't think there's a politician
like economy him anybody in my party or
any party there is stuck up for you know
financial services in London during some
very difficult times and indeed I can't
leave anybody who's gone around the
world championing UK businesses driving
home the message about this all that
contracting genuinely acting as an
ambassador and evangelist for the UK
businesses and that is what I will be if
I'm lucky enough to be elected now I
want to ask you about a subject that you
have been asked about before Nazanin
Sagara - someone who is in jail in Iran
on espionage charges I knew as foreign
secretary wrongly said she was teaching
something that was used at her trial I
mean she felt bad about that well of
course I feel very bad about all the
consular cases in quite just talk about
to come yes I do
and I feel I feel sorry for her for her
daughter for our husband Richard and
I've said this many many times I feel a
deep sense of of anguish for what she
has been going through responsibility
and I but when it comes to
responsibility for what she is suffering
I think it is incredibly important that
we in the UK do not unwittingly give aid
and succor to the people who are
responsible to use my word Sophie to use
your word the people who are really
responsible which is not the Foreign
Office not the former foreign secretary
and then one in London is responsible
for incarcerating Nazanin Sagara
Ratcliffe the people who are responsible
are the Iranian Revolution
anything you do to to exculpate then is
I think a great show because I find that
slightly offensive that you were saying
that anything you do to X completely of
course Iran a responsible course they
are responsible would you say they were
wholly responsible but that doesn't mean
that we you see there were the fact
would you say they were wholly
responsible okay well I'm gonna go to
the words of Richard Ratliff then her
husband he says that your words have had
very traumatic consequences for her it
was used to just to find the second
court case it didn't cause a second
court case but it was used to justify it
and has been used to discredit her ever
since I mean this is this course of
course I do feel a deep sense of anguish
about it as I've said and I've
apologized I think several times I think
in the House of Commons and elsewhere
but I very very important in this
conversation
we don't allow whatever I may have said
or done to cloud the issue which is that
the people incarcerated Nazarene and
others are Qasim sulemani and the
Iranian Revolutionary Guard courts force
and they are doing it illegally they're
doing it in humanely and they should
release her and others and I think it's
very very important that we focus on
that message you see it's not the first
time that something that you've said has
got you into trouble is I just want to
talk a little bit about language that
you've used you've in Collins before
that you've written you've referred to
black people with watermen and smile so
you've talked about in a holy satirical
way by the way bum boys women in burkas
who look like letterboxes and I want to
put it to you that you're not homophobic
you've supported gay rights you've
supported women's right to to wear the
burqa but you'll just say anything to
get a laugh no I think if you look at
each and every one of those columns or
articles you'll find that the quotations
have been wrenched out of context in
many cases made to mean the opposite of
what was intended and actually look at
my record whilst I was mayor of London
or indeed anything I've done look at if
you want to look at somebody whose
campaign fir'd for gender
quality look at what we did in the
Foreign Office where I had a huge
campaign for 12 years of quality
education for every girl in the world
that was actually massively successful
taken up by other countries and which I
believe passionately look at the way I
ran London we you know we had huge
campaigns to protect the rights of women
particularly against violence against
women and you know I I think sometimes
though there is a tendency to as I say
to take words out of context someone who
just won't take responsibility won't
take responsibility for my call your
words on nanny you won't take
responsibility for what you wrote in
York on just wrenched out of context I
mean is that the quality on the country
I look I take full responsibility I say
any but look at what I've actually done
look at what I take full responsibility
for when I took over run in London 11
years ago the city was all in the get in
the grip of the biggest recession than
for 50 years I went through that I went
through the deepest we had riots we had
never knows what we had to get through
get ready for the Olympics I took full
responsibility for all those I took
responsive one thing which was the crime
wave afflicting London but I took
personal responsibility for it and
actually by dint of some very tough
measures by getting the police out on
the street by giving them the power the
political top cover to do stop and
search we got the murder rate down by
50% Hood under 100 a year which is
amazing thing for a city the size of
London and yes I did take personal
responsibility for those because I take
for everything I say and do I'm just I'm
just trying to say all the good things
everything and I and I take personal
responsibility by the way most
importantly for the vote to leave the
European Union I played a part in that
campaign and I'm very proud of what we
did but I take personal responsibility
now for what is happening to our country
for the drift and the dinner and the
indecision and the failure to be
sufficiently robust in the negotiations
which we've seen so far and what
I want to add now is my own ability I
think to lead us out of this mess to get
brexit done by October the 31st and then
to do for the whole country what we did
in London which is to bring it together
we're a great country we're a great
economy let's believe in us I think we
spent three years being told by people
we can't do XYZ because we're not up to
it we can't leave the European Union
because it's all - it's all too alarming
actually it's not this is an
extraordinary country capable of doing
extraordinary things we will get ready
in a very sensible and sober way to come
out on October the 31st with No Deal if
we absolutely have to but we will get a
deal with our friends and partners that
provide security for business for
investment and allows us to carry on and
then we can get on with the agenda that
I've been talking ok you've been
pictured wearing a pair of songs you're
not wearing them today you'll notice of
an Assyrian King to be yes world
captured by he was kinky just tell he
was what he did to his enemies shabam
well he was a vet he where he was pretty
tough on his enemies I he's great he's
great grandfather Sennacherib of course
came down like the wolf on the fold and
his cohorts of gleaming in purple and
gold I put a dog chain through the door
Peter King and then made them live in a
dog kennel well she'd Jeremy hunting why
I mean not good look this in this
election is by no means over Sophie
there's a there's a long way to go
I'm I'm full of admiration for lots of
people in the Cassone but I've never
known a time when there's been so much
talent on the conservative benches I
admire
Jeremy very much and and whatever
happens he will not be in a dog kennel
tell you that much and then just finally
with or without a chain rather than it
just finally skies I suppose
Sky News is holding some debate next
week that he's going to come on you have
just been interrogated by you phone for
a long time I mean how much tougher
cause I mean is it any experience more
brutal and public and tougher than that
I bet
is that I don't or yes well I'm doing
loads of debates and I and I humbly
submit so V there can be no there could
be no more interrogation or catechism
more devastating than an interview then
safely Ridge on Sunday anybody who can
get through severe edge on Sunday you
know deserves them ok thank you very
much